[Music]
well one of the cooler things that we
have got uh since we lived here has been
the tractor
um the tractor where are you going out
of here
you don't want to talk about the tractor
seriously
yep all right
so let's talk about the tractor one of
my more genius purchases
probably the best thing that we've ever
owned has been the tractor
that's arguable yes i thought you didn't
want to talk about the tractor okay
so anyways uh one of the one of the
better things that we probably have ever
purchased here in my opinion not sarah's
has been the tractor uh it's the one
thing that i have probably learned the
most from
and in my opinion we wouldn't be doing
anything that we're doing without it
well if sarah doesn't want to talk about
the tractor that's just fine by me it's
understandable we got the tractor in
march of uh 2017 and it's been a huge
learning curve for me
um
there's been a lot of repairs on it um
it's a pretty old machine though so it's
a 1949
i know uh based on the
stamp that is on the motor that the
motor was made march 28
1949 so
it's always hard to tell with these
tractors what was done over the years
you know what parts were replaced was
this tractor destroyed at one time and
then they took another tractor and
basically
built one tractor out of both tractors
that's hard to say
um
but for all intents and purposes
uh she's a 1949 to me
and um
and it's pretty cool they uh they knew
what they were doing back then um
it's pretty impressive all the little
gadgets i won't go into great detail on
the tractor uh for all the nerds out
there if they're tractor nerds they
probably know everything there is to
know about it but i will show you a few
different cool things that i think are
pretty neat on it
this right here is the fuel shut off
so you got to turn that on it's got that
sediment bowl with a whole bunch of crap
in it as you can see
um one thing that i did add to the
tractor was a battery disconnect um
that's right here it's just basically a
100 amp battery disconnect switch
the reason i added that was i i did have
one of these go bad on me and um
i was about 30 feet away from the
tractor and it tried to start
and
thankfully it wasn't in gear or anything
like that
but that made me nervous enough to put a
battery disconnect on it
just to have one extra safety feature
too for the kids
although they know not to touch things
and they're pretty good at it um
the uh the
cool old switch here that's uh the
starter switch so when you go to start
it up basically you just turn the power
on
uh i replaced the ignition key with an
ignition switch that way i could easily
just kill it if i needed to while it was
out in the field
um
basically just push that pull that make
sure it's in neutral
and there she wanted to start right
right there so
pretty simple uh make sure you got the
gas on otherwise you'll uh
it'll let you know you run out of gas
after a couple of minutes of cruising
around so had that happen a time or two
this here is all brand new this year um
they had a piece that was in here
that uh
got busted off or they they hammered it
off well anyways it's supposed to have
this pin that goes all the way through
the rear so you don't end up busting
these ears off
and uh so i replaced that that was a
little bit of a
to do i had to drill out the old one and
there's a sleeve that goes in there and
that all works i bought this uh rocker
online uh it's pretty cool uh if
anybody's been paying attention they're
yelling at me for running gear on the
top i i know i'm not supposed to be
running gear on the top but for whatever
reason
the pin that i have
isn't long enough to go through the
bottom so i think i'm gonna have to get
in there and do a little sanding so calm
down on that it's okay uh probably the
first thing that i bought when i got the
tractor was that cover right there for
the uh
for the pto i don't want to end up with
my shirt or my sock or a kid's arm or
anything else and that that thing won't
stop turning ever
that's the one thing about these old
tractors is
you know in a way they call them widow
makers or whatever because nothing stops
them you know told sarah if i if i'm out
on the tractor and i have a heart attack
it's either going to end up in the pond
or hit a tree or
flip over in the ditch because there's
nothing that stops these things it just
keeps going
so this one's a four speed with reverse
um it does have a transmission and i
still i put a video out asking for guys
help and i'll just mention it here again
it has a transmission with a high low
gear uh selector and i have yet to have
anybody figure out exactly what
transmission it is so
there's some smart person watching this
video
what transmission has a handle like that
i've only seen one other one online with
the hole in that exact spot all of the
other ones that have the cable
uh cable switch that hole is actually up
on top it's about an inch up so this
one's a little bit different uh they had
cut a hole in the side here
uh to access inside there's kind of like
a a spring and a bolt that hooks to a a
pin for the transmission for that
um other than that i converted it to uh
to 12 volt that was one of the other
earlier things that i did and put this
alternator in um
i've replaced the head gasket i've
i've done all sorts of stuff so
when sarah's joking about not wanting to
hear another dang thing about the
tractor you can believe that i've talked
your ear off about this tractor so but
i'll tell you this i've never heard her
complain when uh
when the driveway's clear of snow and
she didn't lift a finger so i'll tease
her there a little bit
well this is implement row this is where
i
store all the stuff on the edge of the
woods here
i got quite a few different things over
the past few years i've done pretty good
i think as far as cost is concerned
some of these uh can really do some
amazing stuff
as a matter of fact it might kind of
sound silly for this video but i picked
a small piece of land and went out and
used
these to show you guys exactly what they
can do so i hope you appreciate the
effort that i put in for that i'm not
going to do anything i don't have
anything planned to do with that that
land so
it's just going to just a small little
spot just to kind of show you what it
can do
this here is an old john deere discharl
this was a gift from my neighbor a
super super awesome gift i um
i think i told the story in another
video so i'll keep keep it short for
this video but
how i came across this was i was showing
my dad and my father-in-law the back
half of the property
and i walked into the weeds and ran my
shin directly into the side of one of
these things
i couldn't couldn't see the discs under
the grass and uh ran into it and my dad
and i and my uh father-in-law mike we
uncovered it
and my dad said hey it's an old disk he
was all excited and i thought nothing of
it and
then later on down the road after the
whole garden fiasco we had with the
other stupid thing i bought
i thought about this laying out there
and wondered what condition it was in
and
went out and kind of took a better look
at it and
figured it belonged to my neighbor since
he owned my land previous and i called
him up and
asked him about it and
he uh he said yeah if you uh if you want
to get that thing unburied out there
it's yours so i took it back to the
garage and
and tore it completely apart and did a
complete restore and rebuild on it boy
it looked beautiful
when it when it first got pulled out of
the garage after it got all repainted
and everything but
she's got some wear on her now
but it's pretty cool it's got a couple
of uh neat things
it's got this adjustment handle here
with all these notches and basically you
just as you pull this forward it slides
the um carriages and starts to add pitch
to the discs so that you can get more
aggressive with the ground
and actually the back carriage works in
the same fashion
um
basically you can just change uh
whichever holes you want to be hooked
into and that'll change the pitch of the
rear carriage for the people who had
watched the video where i lost this uh
this piece here
that piece is pretty important to me and
i'm glad i found it the reason is is
because that piece locks in the entire
back carriage
so without that piece and i probably
would have a tough time replacing it or
finding another one
it would make the entire back carriage
unusable so i'm pretty excited that i
happen to come across and find it
this was actually sitting directly next
to it out in the weeds and i didn't go
and uncover this for another year after
i got the disc and i called my neighbor
back up and
said boy uh there's something else out
there i'm interested in
and he said i tell you what
clean everything out of there
because there's a whole bunch of crap
laying in there he said clean everything
out of there and lay it out in the yard
so i can take a look at what else is in
there and it's yours so
i took this back to the
to the garage and completely tore it
apart and repainted and
and i i can't remember the name of the
company it's like peterman's or peter
smith or some some company i think in
wisconsin made these
i want to say this thing is probably
was made sometime in the 80s versus the
disc i think the disc was made
uh
somewhere in the 40s if i was to guess
then uh i've seen my uh
my planter
still haven't repaired the front of it
you gotta gotta do that still if you
watch that episode where i
had a little
problem with that and
smash that up a bit
uh this here is a uh a ferguson double
bottom plow uh this one i think was the
first implement that we bought um
bought it from a guy uh
south of the twin cities um
he wanted a reasonable
reasonable price compared to other
people i had been kind of checking out
on craigslist and
so on a trip uh
down to visit some relatives sarah and i
stopped in and bought this plow and
and uh
boy amazing after after uh trying that
that first stupid haro the first year
that didn't do anything
i'll never forget the look on sarah's
face the first time i went by on the
tractor with this plow
and uh
it it absolutely just folds the ground
right over no problem
amazing this is a dearborn 1906 uh
this here
uh it doesn't have a chain on it
typically i'm just storing that on it
this is a
back scoop
um it's a only one direction so you hook
it to the tractor and you have to drive
into whatever you're gonna scoop up
and then uh you can reach this handle
here from the seat and you pull the
handle and the bucket dumps itself so
it's pretty slick
that was a a steal of a deal um
found this for sale about a half hour
from the house and they wanted 20
and i told sarah i said i don't even
care if we use it or don't use it
there's more than 20 worth of steel i'll
cut it up and do something with it if if
we don't do
if we don't use it this we're not going
to talk about this was a failed
experiment
so just get that out of your head
this i bought for uh i think 75 bucks
and they originally had a bale spear
sticking out the rear end of it but when
i saw it for sale i wasn't thinking bale
spear i was thinking other things so i
ended up making this hilling machine
and i uh welded these brackets on here
and uh bought these discs online
and
this thing's a pretty cool machine you
can you can set the pitch and you can
you can hill mound anything you want to
plant it really helps out with our weed
control that way we're not using
chemicals or nothing like that and i've
used it in quite a few videos i'm sure
sure you've seen it uh
seen it featured in a few uh this here
this is kind of sitting a little bit
goofy but this is uh
get her tipped up here
this here is a back blade
that
can be used for moving dirt and
everything like that but mainly i use it
for moving snow
so uh
just hooks up to the tractor on the
front end over here with the
with the three point
and uh you can push or you can drag this
particular
back blade you can spin it 360 degrees
depending on which direction you want to
move it and i also made a video where i
showed i made a custom
pipe
for the bottom of the blade what that
helps out with is if you have a gravel
driveway in the winter time when you're
piling snow you're not pushing gravel
around so that pipe kind of just floats
on top of the gravel makes it so that uh
all you're pushing around is snow
this here
this here is another 196 deerborn uh i
bought this one this uh back bucket
before i bought the other one that i
showed you for 20 bucks i want to say i
paid 100 and something for this one um
maybe 150 or something
but because this one was not in as good
a condition as the one that i picked up
for 20 dollars
i ended up doing a little bit of an
experiment on this you'll notice this
one might look just slightly different
than the uh
than the other one and what i did was i
took the other bracket
that was supposed to come here out the
front
that would hook to the tractor and i cut
these ears off the back and i welded
them off of the back of it
and then i made this uh
as i made that top piece so that it
hooks on with the uh
with the top link across the back and
then i made my custom sized
top link that i don't think they sell or
make anywhere else and
and uh that thing works pretty good it
looks a little ridiculous on the back of
the tractor but believe it or not that
thing really really works good so if
there's something that i want to
back up into and scoop
this is the one that can get it done and
uh
and so far it hasn't failed me at all
i've had it for a couple of years
well anyways that's the tour down
implement row
and all the cool farming stuff that
goes along with the tractor
boy i don't know if we'd be doing as
much as we're doing without that tractor
that thing sure has saved us
and
sure has proven
proven to be a good asset to what we're
doing here
anytime we need to run around and pick
something up
just hop on the tractor and
and go do it
if this is the first video on the series
that you're uh enjoying and
and you've made it through my implement
rant i want to say thank you
um i want to say hit that like button of
course everybody says that you got to
say that otherwise people don't do it
hit that like button and then uh
then youtube thinks it's a good video so
they'll they'll show it to other people
and give them an opportunity to watch it
too so anyways thank you for watching
have a wonderful evening
[Music]
well we're back into the repair shop